[Musica]
bene
ho sempre sognato fin da bambino Io sono
nato a Cremona e poi sono stato
strappato da Cremona di trovarmi su
questo palco con uno spartito Eccoci qua
finalmente e cerchiamo di tradurre
alcune note in qualche parola e in
qualche immagine
vedete questa immagine che è proiettata
dietro di me penso che vi sia nota Io
l'avevo appesa nella mia cameretta da
ragazzo da liceale ed è stata la mia
occasione per riflettere più o meno
consapevolmente sulla complessità che è
diventata il mio Daimon la mia passione
la mia ossessione che mi ha portato
al mio studio alle mie riflessioni
vedete questa poi immagine è un'immagine
di un di un quadro di Moritz Escher un
grande artista del Novecento ed è
diventata una sorta di icona della
complessità ma perché perché rende
visibile la caratteristica principale
della complessità Qual è la
caratteristica principale della
complessità e la circolarità cosa
vediamo in questa immagine vediamo uno
strano anello una mano che disegna una
mano e però la mano disegnata a sua
volta Disegna la mano che la disegnata
che a sua volta Disegna la mano che la
disegnata e così via
vedete non ci sono ben distinte due mani
una mano che disegna e una mano che è
disegnata non c'è da una parte una causa
e dall'altra un effetto che ne consegue
Come in una linea che ha una direzione
Come in una freccia ogni mano è nello
stesso tempo sia causa che effetto
dell'altra mano Insomma c'è una danza
fra le due mani
una danza fra le due mani che fa sì che
emerga si crei un mondo complesso Ma
perché complesso abbiamo sentito
io provo un'altra etimologia complesso
deriva dal verbo latino plecter
intrecciare vuol dire più come insieme
intrecciare tante cose insieme in una
unità più volte nel tempo Sì perché ci
vogliono tante parti tante parti che
interagiscono fra di loro tanti attori
tanti danzatori danzatrici che
interagiscono fra di loro Ma ci vuole
anche tanto tempo per fare emergere la
complessità la complessità è una danza
che crea un mondo se finisce la danza
finisce la complessità
l'abbiamo già detto l'opposto di
complessità non è semplice
è complicato
ciò che è complicato può essere
semplificato può essere scomposto nelle
sue parti Poi può essere ricomposto come
un grande LEGO oppure come un jumbo un
aereo complicatissimo
la semplicità invece può essere la
manifestazione di una straordinaria
complessità pensate allo strizzar
d'occhio che ammicca quanta complessità
produce questo gesto di ammiccamento
semplice che crea un'intesa più
pregnante più profonda di tante parole
può essere semplice come una danza a cui
assistiamo da questo splendido palco
che può apparire semplice armonica Ma
quanta complessità quanto intrecciare
quanto completere produce un gesto un
Armonia tanto semplice ma complessità è
il concetto principale della Scienza
contemporanea in tutti i campi Anzi la
parola
complessità è venuta in Auge proprio
attraverso le scienze e in particolare
attraverso le scienze della natura non
attraverso le scienze
umanistiche hanno cominciato le scienze
della natura la fisica la chimica la
cosmologia a rivelare la complessità dei
nostri mondi dall'universo a quelli
infinitamente piccoli più piccoli
dell'atomo
E che cosa ci dicono le scienze ci
dicono questo avevamo potuto pensare che
i mondi naturali da noi studiati fossero
dei meccanismi perfetti dei meccanismi
complicati appunto retti da leggi
inflessibili e quindi in linea di
principio dei meccanismi prevedibili
controllabili con la scoperta di queste
leggi attraverso la Conoscenza
scientifica
avevamo potuto pensare che l'incertezza
che ovviamente fa parte della nostra
esperienza anche dell'esperienza di noi
scienziati forse dovuta soltanto
all'imperfezione delle nostre conoscenze
un ipotetica conoscenza onnisciente
avrebbe dissolto l'incertezza che appare
nei nostri mondi ma non è così e che non
è così ce lo dicono oggi le stesse
scienze della natura non c'è bisogno
patrimonio del libero arbitrio umano per
trovare l'incertezza nel nostro mondo
le scienze ci dicono che la maggior
parte dei mondi naturali sono piuttosto
delle danze che creano mondi non
prevedibili nel loro decorso in questi
mondi di volta in volta e le cose sono
andate in un certo modo vanno in un
certo modo E certo a posteriori di
fronte a qualcosa che accade in natura
possiamo capire perché le cose sono
andate così o sforzarci di capire
potremmo capire ma le cose potevano
andare in tanti altri modi differenti E
questo a causa della complessità cioè
del continuo intrecciarsi con lettere
tra le parti
c'è una metafora come le immagini le
metafore sono più precise più profonde
persino delle formule matematiche c'è
una metafora che rappresenta bene questa
idea della complessità e ci è nota penso
a tutti e la propose un matematico era
un metereologo soprattutto esattamente
50 anni fa
Edward Lawrence E la propose proprio per
indicare la complessità del sistema
metereologico nel quale appunto tutto è
connesso con tutto tutto si richiama con
tutto
e la metafora dell'effetto farfalla il
battito d'ali di una farfalla sul cielo
di Tokyo Può avere effetti importanti
sul tempo che farà a New York pochi
giorni dopo una piccola trascurabile
causa un piccolo trascurabile vento come
il battito d'ali di una farfalla di
solito di pertinenza per l'immaginazione
dei bambini
dello stare insieme degli Innamorati dei
versi di un poeta No una piccola
trascurabile causa come il battito d'ali
di una farfalla può avere effetti enormi
lontani nello spazio e nel tempo bene
questa complessità caratterizza anche il
senso profondo del nostro tempo del
tempo che viviamo siamo come in un
disegno di Escher nel mondo globale
tutto è connesso e questo è rivelato
bene dalle crisi che stiamo vivendo il
cambiamento climatico la pandemia la
guerra tornata drammaticamente in una
piccola regione dell'Europa e che in
pochi giorni ha trasformato come un
effetto farfalla il mondo intero
il battito d'ali di una farfalla di un
microscopico virus sul cielo della
regione di One in Cina Può avere effetti
importanti l'abbiamo vissuto sul tempo
che farà a Cremona e poi nel mondo
intero
pochi giorni dopo
la crisi della pandemia che abbiamo
vissuto in questi tre anni si è
manifestata come uno strano anello
simile a questo
disegnato da Escher
Ma qui le mani sono tante Non sono due è
un anello fatto di tante mani
intrecciate che non possono essere
separate le une dalle altre la crisi
della pandemia Certo è una crisi
sanitaria l'abbiamo sofferta temuta
ma è nello stesso tempo tante altre
crisi è una crisi ecologica è una crisi
scientifica è una crisi economica
antropologica psicologica esistenziale e
spirituale e ogni crisi disegna diciamo
così le altre crisi che a loro volta
disegnano le crisi che le hanno
disegnate e così via come in un
complessissimo disegno alla Escher e
anche in questo caso la sfida della
complessità si impone Innanzitutto come
impossibilità di semplificare un tessuto
inestricabile di concause ed
interdipendenze Sì perché ormai nel
tempo della complessità che il tempo
globale viviamo in una ecumene
completamente umanizzata antropizzata
diciamo noi professori che è la terra
dove ogni evento locale come il battito
d'ali di una farfalla può comportare
conseguenze che si amplificano su scala
globale perciò un mondo complesso è un
mondo inevitabilmente
incerto
Ma questo fatto non ci rende impotenti E
soprattutto non deve portare
alla rassegnazione piuttosto questo
mondo complesso mette in gioco la nostra
responsabilità Sì perché Perché la
nostra responsabilità oggi si estesa
verso nuovi ambiti verso le specie
viventi verso la biodiversità verso gli
ecosistemi verso il pianeta nella sua
interezza e la nostra responsabilità
si è estesa verso la possibilità della
stessa sopravvivenza della nostra
umanità della nostra specie nel futuro
ed è questo il dramma la spada di
Damocle che pesa su di noi in questi
giorni in cui drammaticamente è
diventato
possibile
l'uso delle armi nucleari in cui è già
diventata realtà il cambiamento
climatico che mette a repentaglio in un
futuro non troppo lontano la stessa
sopravvivenza della nostra umanità oggi
a motivo della potenza tecnologica e
della interdipendenza planetaria cioè
appunto della complessità dell'intreccio
di tutto con tutto è diventato
disastroso è diventato potenzialmente
suicida
continuare la semplificazione in cui
ciascuno vince a spese degli altri le
nazioni vincono presumono di poter
vincere a spese delle altre in cui
l'umanità intera presume di poter
vincere
a spese della terra della biosfera per
la prima volta possiamo perdere tutti
insieme il rischio inedito nuovo e che
ci possano essere non più vincitori e
vinti da una parte e dall'altra ma solo
vinti Allora per concludere il virus il
clima la guerra che cosa ci rivelano ci
rivelano che la solidarietà in qualche
modo sinonimo di complessità la
solidarietà è ormai una necessità
imposta dalla complessità della
condizione umana nel tempo globale siamo
accomunati da uno stesso destino siamo
accomunati dagli stessi pericoli dagli
stessi problemi di vita e di morte un
destino che accomuna fra loro tutti i
popoli della terra e
Ricordiamocelo oggi che accomuna fra di
loro l'umanità intera con la terra
stessa
nessuno si può salvare da solo nel tempo
della complessità come è stato detto
Siamo tutti sulla stessa barca ma per
orientare la rotta di questa barca
Abbiamo bisogno di cambiare gli occhiali
con cui guardiamo il mondo Abbiamo
bisogno di occhiali che ci consentano di
vedere la complessità del nostro mondo
di un mondo in cui tutto è connesso per
poterlo abitare in un modo non auto
distruttivo e questa lo dico a tutti noi
lo dico in particolare i ragazzi e gli
insegnanti che su cui numerosi È una
straordinaria sfida per la nostra
educazione Grazie
[Applauso]